nur weil er in ruhe fernsehen gucken
wollte tötete stief papa dominik sbb
luca unglaublich er packte seinen
stiefsohn und erstickte ihn mit einer
kinder decke qualvoll und die mutter von
luca vanessa schaute erst nach ihrem
kind als der film zu ende war
kurz vor weihnachten 2009 10 hatte
dominik es den acht monate alten
säugling in der wohnung der kindsmutter
in gemünden gepackt und erstickt weil
sein schreien beim fernsehen gucken
störte laut anklage war es nicht das
erste mal dass dominic s ausrastete
insbesondere wenn luca schrie und der
angeschuldigte mit dem kind alleine in
der wohnung war soll es zu gewalttätigen
übergriffen gekommen sein
der angeklagte hatte eine tiefe
abneigung gegenüber dem kind entwickelt
und sich in der partnerschaft mit der
mutter des kindes gestört gefühlt
die 21 jährige musste vor gericht rede
und antwort stehen
denn zeugen haben ihre wohnung als
kiffer höhle beschrieben das jugendamt
war insgesamt 21 mal in der wohnung
trotzdem wurde das ermittlungsverfahren
wegen misshandlung von schutzbefohlenen
gegen sie inzwischen eingestellt die
staatsanwaltschaft wirft dominik es vor
dem jungen mit stumpfer gewalt
malträtiert und erstickt zu haben
sie fordern zwölf jahre haft heute war
die urteilsverkündung
unser reporter jörg völkerling hat für
uns diesen prozess verfolgten ist uns
jetzt auch zugeschaltet guten abend jörg
wichtigste frage welches urteil ist
heute gefallen
elf jahre haft wegen totschlags
man könnte sagen dass der ursprünglich
wegen mordes angeklagter dominik es
damit billig davongekommen ist
tatsächlich hat dass ein verteidiger
aber nur sieben jahre wegen
körperverletzung mit todesfolge verlangt
und dem jugendamt eine mitschuld
zugewiesen das bei 21 besucher nicht
erkannt habe dass der kleine lokal in
einer kiefer bude leben musste der
richter sagte aber ganz deutlich
dominique es hätte sehr viel billiger
als mit elf jahren davonkommen können
mit weniger haft wenn er einmal die
wahrheit gesagt hätte doch noch am
ersten verhandlungstag sagt er habe das
kind ja nur liebevoll eingepackt
stattdessen sagten wenig darauf kurzer
zeit darauf zeugen aus die mit ihm nach
der feststellung des todes von luca in
der klinik auch zu gefahren waren
da sagte er na ja der tod sei ja nicht
so schlimm dann setzt man jetzt die
hormone ab und mache ich mein neues kind
großes thema bei diesem prozess war auch
in die fan der angeklagte überhaupt zum
tatzeitpunkt schuldfähig war
wie wurde das jetzt am ende eingeschätzt
und was war da überhaupt das thema was
wurde dort besprochen
ja also er war schuldfähig er konnte das
unrecht seiner tat einsehen der richter
sagte er habe drei bis fünf minuten in
das gesicht des sterbenden kindes
geschaut er habe zugeschaut wie es
stirbt unter seinen händen und das
einfügen den händen
und die hat regelmäßig zwar cannabis
geraucht auch an diesem tag aber das hat
ihnen nicht beeinträchtigt da war daran
gewohnt das hat ihn sogar sanftmütiger
gemacht die gutachterin attestierte ihm
aber eine persönlichkeitsstörung die
durch empathie losigkeit aggressivität
seien ausdruck findet das erfüllte aber
nicht mal ansatzweise die kriterien für
eine schwere seelische abartigkeit die
für eine strafminderung ausschlaggebend
gewesen ihre grausame bilder die wir
dort jetzt von der erzählt bekommen
vielen dank für deine berichterstattung
danke mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren